a day after a coup in myanmar
soldiers on the street are a stark
reminder of the new military regime
in yangon banks and shops reopened as
the city seemed to be quietly returning
to normal
but the mood among the people here
seemed low as they digested what had
happened
when i heard the news i couldn't believe
it i'm sad i'm sad for the people
i feel pain in my heart i think people
are going to face trouble
i can't even eat or sleep we are not
strong enough to do
something back to them we don't have
power they seize the power because they
have guns
we have nothing on monday the military
detained de facto leader aung san tsuchi
and other prominent political figures
since the arrests
some regional ministers and lawmakers
have been released
in a country where she and her nld party
remain extremely popular
winning a landslide victory in november
elections this coup will undoubtedly be
unwanted by many
well all the people i've met men and
women
even children don't want to return to
military rule
you know and they hate even the thought
of it even the very sound of it they
didn't want it but what can they do
the nld party has released a statement
attributed to aung san tsuchi
calling for the people to protest
against the military's actions
all the voters who gave their backing to
us in the 2020 general election
should follow org sansuchi's
instructions to carry
out civil disobedience
that call has been widely shared across
social media
here on the streets of yangon it seems
like business as usual
but although it's calm for now voices of
descent
are starting to be heard the nld is
calling for the immediate release of
those who have been arrested
a party spokesperson says su chi is in
good health
and as the sun goes down the sounds of
resistance can be heard in the city
people striking pans and drums from
their balconies
and sounding their car horns all in
protest
against the military coup ali fowl
yangon al jazeera